I want to jump back to 2017 here is Ben
Shapiro on Joe Rogan warning about all
of this stuff
what scares the out of me is when
you hear these stories about people
deciding that their child who's like
eight or nine years old beyond belief
it's scary because you like a nine year
like a 17 year old doesn't know that was
a thing about the Ruby Rose girl she was
saying that when she was young when she
was a teenager she wanted to be a man
she wanted to be transgender and that
she had gone through that phase now
she's so happy that she didn't do
anything right well they say that that
80 percent of kids who experience any
sort of gender dysphoria as children
grow out of it so when you have a
society that reinforces it and then in
Canada they're now having they're
passing laws now that say that if a kid
says you know you have a girl and the
girl says I'm a boy and she's three that
the government can come into your house
and take the kid because obviously if
you if you don't want a humor the kid
and get the kid treatment or surgery or
or hormone blockers then you're
obviously doing something wrong to the
kid this is just it's insane first of
all if anyone tried to do that with my
kid I would meet him at the door with a
gun I mean that this is this is the kind
of stuff where you're talking legit
Civil War like when when you say that
the government can take people's kids
from from them because the government
knows better than you how to parent your
kids on basic things like are you a boy
or a girl you know that clip right there
what Ben said at the end like uh if you
tried to take my kids away you would
meet uh me at the door with a gun that
went very viral people tried to cancel a
Ben that he was threatening law
enforcement and everything else but this
idea that the state could take your kids
away I have Phoenix doing a little
digging right now but just over the last
couple days California has basically
said that if you as a parent do not
affirm what your child is saying about
their gender that the state actually
could get involved that's literally
happening in California right at this
very moment okay I got some info on that
under California's
ab957 a parent could lose custody for
not quote affirming whatever their child
believes about their gender here the
bill author defends this bill using
example of a seven-year-old who
announces their gender doesn't match the
their sex so we'll we'll play the video
that that's referencing we'll play that
on tomorrow's show but it is literally
happening right now and remember as I
always say we should not be calling this
gender affirming surgery the least
affirming thing you could do to a child
is chop their genitals off right that is
not affirming their gender it's actually
pretty unaffirming of their gender uh
also Ben makes an interesting point that
I think is is worth repeating that 80
percent of these kids outgrow this that
also seems to be why this radical
movement is going after the kids and
going after them younger and younger and
younger first off all of you everyone
watching this has met a five year old at
some point most of you probably were
five-year-olds five-year-olds do not
think about these things seven-year-olds
do not think about sex and gender and
any of these things so once you can get
in their minds and start confusing them
think about the Litany of other things
that you can then get them to be
confused about and that seems to be what
our corporations and what our government
want
[Music]
foreign